so on this channel I vlog about all
sorts of things pretty much anything
that I think can make life a little more
action-packed and free that includes
brain training working out muscle fiber
recruitment productivity and also coding
and of all those things the thing I get
asked about probably most often is how
do you begin programming where as a good
place to learn coding which programming
language should you learn well that's
the right question
[Music]
today the program is a great idea for a
ton of different reasons first and
foremost it's excellent brain training
when you're programming you're thinking
in an abstract way you're having to
think creatively and use your
resourcefulness and it's just a kind of
mental exercise where you're holding
these ideas in your head coming up with
solutions to problems and there's
nothing quite like it and I think it's
fantastic for increasing your creativity
and your ability to hold information in
your brain it's great for your working
memory I've done a video on that watch
it and of course you can also use it for
ton of other things programming is of
course great for business and your
career opportunities but it's also great
for making things for yourself a lot of
people think of programming or something
they do in order to make a program
that's going to make them rich but
actually programming can be very useful
just for making tools to help you with
the things you do every day I make
programs that help me with my writing
work for instance but yet programming
has actually also brought me a ton of
opportunities in my career and just in
life so if you've been following me on
social media and watching my channel for
a while then you might know that I
created an app called multi screen
multitasking this turned out to be quite
a big hit and I was so proud of that cuz
it's just an idea I had on my own I
learned how to code it and it just took
off so just from the just from my own
bedroom I counter and built this thing
that ended up being really successful
for me and that ended up being
pre-installed on over a hundred thousand
handsets in India so that was very
exciting and that then led to the
opportunity to work with ColdFusion to
go go on the boxis launcher which was
his design and an awesome creation and I
was lucky enough to handle the coding
element of it and that then led to the
opportunity for me to write development
articles and programming posts for
Android Authority which later evolved
into creating video reviews the new
handsets and getting to test out cool
technology eventually got to fly over to
San Francisco and meet the team that was
very recent that was also an awesome
opportunity and then on top of all that
I've recently been able to write a book
on unity development and I've had my
first properly published book which just
recently went onto Amazon so check that
out if you're interested in learning
more but the point I'm trying to make
here is that
programming opens up doors and it
creates opportunities and there's done
an awful lot for me and I'm not even the
best programmer by any stretch of the
imagination I would say I'm average at
best I've taught myself I didn't do a
degree um I don't have a computer
science degree and everything I've
needed to learn I've just sat down and
learned it so it can be done and I
actually think that's one of the things
that helped me to teach other people
because I understand what you're going
through when you try and learn I know
how difficult it can be to pick up a new
programming language and that's why I'm
going to share with you here how you can
develop your coding skills from naught
and then learn how to do some of this
cool stuff too so the first question
that a lot of people ask me when they
want to learn about programming is which
programming language should they learn
and that's obviously a pretty good place
to start there's a ton of them as you
probably know this Java C sharp C++ C is
basic there's Kotlin there's Python and
people have no idea where to start what
they need to learn and there's no easy
answer to this the best answer is that
you should learn the language that
allows you to make the thing you want to
make so for instance if you want to make
an Android app than the official
programming language for Android is Java
although Google has just begun to
support Kotlin out of the box with
Android studio so you now have two
options for officially supported
programming languages if you want to
make computer game in unity then you
might learn Java or you might learn
c-sharp if you want to create an iOS app
then you might create something using
objective-c or you might learn Swift so
the option you pick is going to depend
on what it is you want to build if you
want to build a website then you'll need
HTML and CSS and I'm not gonna run
through all the different options right
here the best thing to do is to say I
want to make an app or I want to make an
Android app or I want to make a computer
game for the PC search it in Google and
find what the best recommendations are
you'll probably see there's a couple of
different options and you should take
whichever route is probably the
officially most supported one and also
the easiest one the one that will give
you the results you want the quickest
whilst also giving you useful skills
that will be transferable to other
project later on the best way I think to
learn anything is to know what you want
to do with it
then learn the skills you need to do
that things don't sit down say I want to
learn programming that's too broad it's
too mammoth the tasks instead sit down
and say I want to make an app that does
X and then what you need to do is you
need to learn the specific skills to
allow you to do that and that
contextualizes the things you learn so
instead of just thinking I'm learning a
command that does something very vague
instead you're learning a command in
order to do this specific thing and you
can see its usefulness right there and
you can put it into your program and see
how it sits with all the other commands
and statements you've learned obviously
pick something easy and this is where a
lot of people I think go quite wrong and
I've never understood it myself people
say to me I want to make an app and I'm
like great what's it going to be in
there like it's a revolutionary app it's
going to connect people in a way that's
never been connected before and I'm like
so you want it so it's cloud based and
it's revolutionary it needs to work on a
lot of different devices probably it's
far too ambitious if it's your first app
don't make your first app something
really ambitious make your first app by
calculator or make your first app a word
processor the first app I made was a new
keyboard for Android which has slightly
bigger keys I went on to make a word
count app and all that did was count the
number of words you pasted into a text
box so basically pick an idea that's
easy you might have that grand idea for
something amazing but don't make that
your first project I mean why would you
make your first project something easy
can still be original still be useful
still be something that you hope will
sell but don't make it into something
that's going to be hugely difficult to
program currently something simple that
you are passionate about and that you
think will be rewarding and then ask
yourself by searching on Google what is
the best language to make this thing for
this platform and then learn the
specific skills that you need to make
that thing probably start out by reading
a basic overview book so if you want to
learn Java for Android then you just
read a book called Java for Android if
you're anything like me then it will
start to go over your head once you get
past about chapter 4 that's fine put it
to one side and start implementing what
you have learned into that app that
you're building and then as you get
stuck on things just Google like how do
I access images on on a device in
Android studio how do I use strings in
Java and etc and as you do this
you'll build up a working knowledge and
I'll still be loads you don't know but
that's actually the way with programming
you often don't know the majority until
you need it and even the stuff you do
know you often have to look up online to
remember the syntax and how to phrase it
so don't worry about learning everything
just worry about building the thing you
want do your research to find what the
easiest way to start with is and also
what the most official default way to
start is once you have decided the
project you want to work on and the
platform you're targeting then you'll
need to install a few things on your
computer in order to get started and to
create the window where you're gonna
actually start editing the code first
you'll need to download the programming
language or the interpreter so if you
want to learn Python then you'll need to
learn then you need to download Python
if you want to learn Java then you'll
need to download the JDK which is the
Java development kit then you want an
IDE
that's an integrated development
environment and that's where you enter
the code so you download the interpreter
so that your computer understands it and
then you enter the code and run it and
debug it in the IDE and you might need
additional bits for example if you're
creating Android apps you'll need the
apk so that's gonna sound a little bit
confusing but again you can do all this
by searching on Google once you know the
platform you need just do setting up
Android studio development or setting up
unity development but if you want to
learn to code even more quickly and you
want the end result to be even better
then you can try implementing some
accelerated learning techniques as well
so of course accelerated learning
techniques of strategies that can be
applied to any kind of learning in order
to learn more quickly to get rid of that
whole notion that you need 10,000 hours
to become a master so one example is
what I just recommended that you start
on a project instead of just trying to
learn programming and when you structure
your learning in this way it gives it
more context as I said and makes it
easier for you to visualize how things
work and also to know what you need and
to see how it all works together this
idea was also outlined in another book
called the first 20 hours and there it's
called the target performance level so
the idea here is that you come up with a
target that you want to achieve and then
you learn what you need in order to
achieve that target and of course if you
want to continue learning you then
create a slightly harder target and the
way you might apply this to something
else such as learning a language is you
may say for instance I want to be able
to order my lunch
in a restaurant that's what I need to
learn another option is the Fineman
technique and the basic idea behind this
is that you learn enough in order to
teach you try and explain what you've
just learned and then you look for
stumbling blocks areas where things get
complicated or where you can't quite
come up with a good metaphor and that's
probably a weakness in your own
knowledge and like I said I've been
teaching tutorials and writing this book
and that's actually helped me to
accelerate and improve my programming
skills massively because I need to
really understand it in order to explain
it simply so try that try writing down
what you've learned is that you're
teaching someone else if you can sell
that writing then even better and
there'll always be a home for it on the
bionaire of course and then finally you
have the disk technique which is
recommended by Tim Ferriss and I don't
remember that off the top of my head so
it's deconstructing selection sequencing
and stakes basically this involves
setting stakes for yourself to make sure
that you actually do it for instance you
will get slapped if you don't learn
programming it means looking at the best
order to do things in perhaps that means
starting from the end and that's a good
example as well in programming it's
often a good idea to take a finished
product and then to deconstruct it to
reverse-engineer it and see how it
worked and sequencing involves come out
with the best sequence in order to learn
each step when doing this he also breaks
it down into further smaller categories
I highly recommend the book before our
chef if you want to learn more about his
recommendations for accelerated learning
one of the best tips in there is just to
go to someone who knows their stuff and
ask them and that's how I got my start
in programming T so I'm very
knowledgeable told me a little bit about
programming and basic and from that I've
learned everything else and that's one
last thing to bear in mind when you
learn one programming language it
becomes much easier to pick up others
that's because you'll find that a lot of
the rules and the syntax are the same I
wrote a post recently on the bio near
about learning programming without
programming where it tells you about the
structure and how it works without
actually using any of the syntax if
you're interested in that the link will
be in the description down below
basically once you understand variables
and once you understand conditional
statements you can do pretty much
anything and the rest is just syntax oh
look at that if you're looking for an
easy project to get started with and I
do highly recommend
unity is a good place to start if you
want to create an Android app which is
my specialty so unity is a game engine
and an IDE and it basically removes the
need for a lot of code whilst making the
code that you do enter quite logical and
streamlined so it's a great place to
start with Android development and
especially if you set yourself the task
of making something very simple like a
very simple platformer or a very simple
infinite Runner and you can learn a lot
of syntax and basics of programming
there that's my friend you can actually
make a platformer game or even a 3d game
in a matter of hours or days as opposed
to years so a great place to start out
and it's all very rewarding cuz you can
see it working there on the screen
unity is also cross-platform meaning you
can publish to Android iOS or the PC so
don't be afraid of programming it's
complicated it looks impossible but if
you take it one step at a time
and don't worry about learning the whole
thing it's actually a lot easier than
you think and it's incredibly rewarding
and I'm gonna be talking in the future
about the nature of focus and
concentration and you'll see why
programming has the power to make you
incredibly focused so stay tuned for
that as well as all of my usual stuff I
do still have that Bruce Lee diet on the
way I have a post about the GDP pocket
on the way I'm going to be talking about
the best training tools I'm gonna be
talking about some book recommendations
for fitness I'm gonna be talking about
some cool productivity tips etc so if
you like the sounds of that then please
stay tuned and I'll see you for the next
one thanks a ton for watching if you
found this useful and interests me
please consider liking and sharing it
really helps me out and I love hearing
your comments down below so please post
there if you have anything to contribute
check out my social media on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram where I'm trying
to be more active and yeah thanks a ton
again for all of you who watch regularly
because yeah I love making this channel
I'm sorry it's been a couple of weeks
since the last video I am increasing the
output I've been working on some cool
stuff that I'll be sharing with you over
the next couple of months so stay tuned
for that thanks once again and bye for
now